عمليه الاجلاء مستمره عبر منفذ المنفذ
البحري الوحيد في البلاد ميناء بورسودان
اضافه الى مطار بورسودان الدولي نتحدث عن
هذه الصوره اذا هذه بعض يعني هذه جزء من
سلسله عمليات اجلاء
تمت خلال اربعه ايام ماضيه هذه الصوره
تحديدا هي عباره عن نحو 450
شخصا موظفون في الامم المتحده والوكالات
التابعه لها تم اجلائهم او يجري اجلائهم
في هذه اللحظات عبر السفينه الحربيه
الفرنسيه لارين هذه السفينه كانت رابطه
منذ الصباح تنتظر الاجراءات ان تكتمل
للموظفين الامويين الذين كان بصحبتهم رئيس
البعثه الامميه
لدعم الانتقال السياسي في
الذي كان حريصا فيما يبدو ان يودع هؤلاء
الموظفين بعائلاتهم اضافه الى 54 موظف
اممي هناك اكثر من 200 من الرعايه
الفرنسيين الذين كانوا موجودين هنا في
السودان قاموا ايضا
بيقام ايضا يعني تتم عمليه ايلائهم مع
الموظفين الامميين كانت هناك عده عمليات
لاجلاء الرعايه جانب بينهم اثنان صينيا